guess who's back welcome to countless if
you like it you pay if you don't like it
chance pay anyway how much you charge
for them leaves if you want to be this
these Child beyoncé of course you $200
and if you want to be Beyonce featuring
James beneath all that is she sees
nowhere in every neighborhood there's a
place hopes to get together to talk
about their dreams to share their
frustrations and maybe even tell it
Joker - excuse me but I don't like to
get involved in petty argument that's
primarily what you did pretty much all
you do it's the home away from home and
these aren't just friends they're fan
her out oh there's a Gus the only man
that you could trust is the one of above
each one of y'all want a super thug
that's got three degrees from Harvard
meanwhile you pass up corny dudes like
Gerard every day don't know no moist
Duncan Hines ass do like Gerard guys I'm
standing right here I can hear you
don't stop playing
oh he'll take me too long to get back up
only ripping out the neighborhood no
more I'm trying to get that call in the
middle of the night saying my son is
locked up or worse some people downtown
ain't moving fuss we gotta fix our
problems myself the barbershop is the
pillar of the neighborhood so we turn
the shop into our safe space with free
cuts in styling this love is worth I bet
he won't be talking back to it mama no
mo give me Jojo
we'll never give up your father be proud
of everything that's going on hashtag
barbershops save the neighborhood is
trending on Twitter can I get a selfie
with you what the white girls want they
lost did you tell me it was awesome
white people love you go awesomeness
it's my season we Jesus